[Música]
ó eu queria começar contando pra vocês
um pouco como foi esse processo de
receber o convite para falar no ted e eu
sabia que tinha coisas interessantes
aqui para dividir com vocês mas é
difícil organizar se em 15 minutos
18 mas e aí eu comecei a pensar como é
que eu vou de onde o comércio essa
conversa
e aí muito recentemente porque estou há
20 dias tentando construir essa conversa
mas foi agora que seu funcionamento
assim sabe quando vai chegando perto
parece que a coisa vem aí eu comecei eu
mesmo não me dei conta e todas as
vésperas de completar 54 anos daqui a
três dias a publicar que presentaço né
poder compartilhar do tempo de
experiência às vezes meu adversário um
presente antecipado
e aí eu não imaginava que seria em
primeiro lugar foi pra mim é uma visita
à minha vida de estudante uma visita é a
minha infância minha vida profissional
as minhas escolhas quando é que eu
escolhi isso quando eu escolhi quando é
que escolhi essa profissão e vem uma
lembrança muito claro em mais ou menos
uma semana de uma fala do meu pai que
dizia assim eram os três filhos e ele
sempre dizia aproveitem a isso ele e
minha mãe mas ele mais ainda ele era
aquele cara autodidata que ficava ali
acompanhando o estudo mais de perto e
ele dizia assim aproveitem a escola
porque é lá onde tudo acontece é de lá o
ponto de partida para o mundo
então fui me dando conta preparando essa
conversa de que foi lá na escola com
essa fala inicial do meu pai foi por
isso que entrei para a escola eu sempre
amei escola a escola pra mim sempre foi
um lugar de encantamento
eu sempre me emocionei com a escola e
com as coisas da escola e era uma coisa
tão incrível e me lembrando só
lembranças que até uma semana atrás dela
estavam apagados de que eu ficava na
escola pensando cá que é aquilo que vai
dizer o lugar de descobrir é um lugar de
aprender é o lugar de tirar dúvida é o
lugar de investigar as curiosidades
é dali que você vai partir pra voar e aí
eu me lembro que era o meu nome
como uma aluna mediana e mais que eu
curti essa coisa de olhar o professor
então muitas vezes eu ficava no recreio
não ia pra o recreio que gostava de ver
professora preparando os materiais era
uma lembrança que eu também não tinha
então esse lugar do sonho eu ficava lá
escarafunchando eu gostava da professora
da época do mimeógrafo que que cheirinho
de álcool que a professora ficava
rodando é as atividades alguém é da
época do miami bufa né esse selo era
cheio de escola e eu ficava que ela vai
fazer o quê pra gente fazer hoje é
tarefa de casa de manhã tinha uma coisa
que era me tocava o coração e ali eu
entendia que deus que me lembrei talvez
eu já soubesse disso mas eu lembrei
agora nessas últimas semanas que foi ali
exatamente ali que eu escolhi não sair
mais da escola
então eu escolhesse professora ali eu
devia ter o qi alfabetização sete anos
oito anos e ela mesma coisa de que eu
dava aula para a boneca de papel sou do
tempo da boneca de papel e meu pai
negociava assim tipo se a gente lê se
alguma coisa durante a semana no final
de semana garrafa de bi e ganhar uma
boneca de papel que eu dava aula para as
bonecas de papel e assim foi me formei
professora naquilo no rio de janeiro nem
um pouquinho
uma parte disso fora do rio mas no final
do magistério foi aqui no instituto de
educação e foi ali que eu me tornei uma
educadora e sempre foi uma professora e
talvez um pouco fora da caixinha aquele
livro uma professora muito maluquinha eu
já recebi de presente de muitas crianças
e adolescentes que eu atendo acho que me
identifico com ele e durante assim o
tempo de professor eu era aquela
professora que gostava de escarafunchar
eu gostava de entender como cada um
aprende a porque uma coisa motivar uma
pessoa mas não motivava outra porque que
um aprende de um jeito e outro aprendia
de outro jeito
por conta disso fui me especializar em
psicopedagogia que é uma conversa mesmo
né entre a aprendizagem e um ser que
aprendi isso abre um horizonte então
apesar da minha atuação de 30 anos em
escola nos últimos dez anos eu 12 anos
eu juntei o meu trabalho escola primeiro
como professor durante muitos anos
depois como coordenadora pedagógica
depois como orientadora educacional
porque era o caminho de mais fundo
eu queria ir mais fundo queria entender
o que acontecia e aí veio o consultório
que era um espaço onde me dava
mas a expansão de atuação então durante
os dois últimos anos eu como conciliou o
trabalho da educadora com o meu trabalho
de terapeuta e aí eu fiquei pensando
então quer dizer que eu sou uma
educadora e terapeuta uma terapeuta
educadora alguma coisa por aí que as
pessoas me perguntam e eu falo eu acho
que eu sou uma educadora e terapeuta
matéria o educador
só que assim tem alguma coisa que
acontece nos últimos cinco anos que me
toca profundamente que é como eu sei
como eu recebo né na verdade até 15 anos
atrás eu tinha um público assim a
adolescente ea gente dizia se que hoje a
adolescente ainda brincava com os
adolescentes e dizer sabe o que é todo
do essência uma época de crescer e ser
feliz se eu pudesse eu desligava a vocês
aos 13 ligava aos 18 mas eu não posso
não é porque também nesse momento onde a
gente está colocando a energia para
crescer que a gente sente dor no osso
nem a dor do crescimento e também onde a
gente vai crescer no aprendizado da vida
ea lidar com as coisas com os desafios
com os esforços necessários então só que
acontece isso há dez anos atrás de cinco
anos para cá assustadoramente
eu trabalho com crianças de sete anos
até 27 anos eu digo crianças de 7 e
adolescentes 27
essa é a minha margem de trabalho hoje e
eles chegam assim desanimados
desmotivados sofridos machucados mesmo
quando eu digo machucado muitas estou
contando isso alguém fala ai você com
essa linguagem figurativa falo não estou
falando sério e machucado de cortado
cortado pela gillette cortada com
estilete sabe de um estudantes em taikos
a perna e olhar e falar só temos
marquinhos esquisitas tem um igual aqui
uma glock uma glock que é isso que
acontece
ou então aquele calor de 40 graus ea
pessoa de moletom
tem alguma coisa esquisita tem jogo que
está acontecendo ea pessoa me mostra
toda machucada está machucada e não sabe
explicar direito é uma dor é uma dor e
eu me machuco pra está a analisar uma
dor que eu também não sei direito onde
ela vem
na verdade a gente vai investigar junto
isso junto com esse estado vem sempre
uma sensação do lado de lá de que eu não
sou capaz de que eu não vou por esse
mundo de escola não isso não é pra mim e
não sofrimento sozinho a família sofre
junto o professor sofre junto à escola
sofre junto sofre todo mundo junto e é
uma sensação de que eu acho que não vou
conseguir recursos e odeio estudar teve
algum colega que começou deixa eu escuto
muito isso então a primeira coisa que a
gente vai trabalhar juntos é vamos
separar o que é não gostar de estudar
formalmente do que é não gostar de
aprender porque isso é um conceito que
se confunde
muitas vezes eu tenho aprendente em
potencial alguém curioso criativo e que
acha que não há ninguém que não gosta de
estudar formalmente ou não sabe estudar
formalmente porque muitas vezes é isso
que acontece
e aí a gente ali começam a lhe vizinho
ao mesmo tempo
é nessa conversa toda eu vou observando
assim que é preciso mobilizar todos os
segmentos porque a gente está no momento
que a gente pode achar culpados né gente
pode dizer nossas famílias que trabalham
nove horas por dia de mandato da escola
ou trabalha 12 horas por dia não são
esses professores que também tomar conta
da vida eles têm que de uma escola
escolhe quem tem ou não direito do aluno
a esses alunos que não querem nada copa
do brasil então a gente pode entrar
nessa vai pedir vamos achar os culpados
mas eu acho que não se trata disso
eu acho que o importante neste momento é
o que funciona no meu trabalho e quando
eu vejo que esse quadro começa a mudar
quando a gente senta junto pra pensar a
gente senta junto para que que tá
acontecendo porque esses meninos
machucados e aí hoje foi muito
interessante no final das contas a dor
está aqui no final porque foi costurando
né as idéias e pensando a medicação
aquela primeira o primeiro número
musical nossa é o que eu vivo
os adolescentes medicados e crianças
muito novas medicado e dizendo eu fui
muito esquisita quando todo esse remédio
não gosto de mim quando eu tomei remédio
eu sou radicalmente contra nada às vezes
a medicação em algum momento é
importante só que a medicação ela pode é
colocar o aluno de frente professor mas
em medicação não traz o sentido para a
gente aqui tenha sentido precisa do
outro e por isso que pra mim hoje foi
muito interessante também
a minha fala foi ganhando sentido quando
fui vendo vocês
quando fui ver a reação de vocês com os
meus colegas falavam quando fui
escutando como é necessária essa relação
com o outro que sentido se estabeleça e
aí nesse momento me vejo a artesã
então eu escolhi ser professora
educadora virei terapeuta pela demanda
mas que eu amo o que eu faço e me vejo
costurando construindo pontes porque na
verdade a gente faz também com a
sociedade nessa é culpa da sociedade com
a sociedade mas a sociedade somos nós
então eu me vejo conversando com a
escola conversando com a família
conversando com o aluno conversando com
o professor escutando esses segmentos
porque de verdade o nó meu trabalho é
que todo mundo tem razão quando escutam
um pai uma mãe que me disse olha não me
vai mandar fazer isso não porque eu
cheguei em casa nova depois gotham anda
eu vou matar essa criatura se eu tiver
que chegar alguma coisa clara de escola
ou quando o professor falou olha eu
quero olhar eu quero poder olhar é
finita tempo porque tem muito conteúdo
para colocar então o vilão o conteúdo
claro que não tão escuro perguntas como
adorei a história da fórmula 1 porque eu
tenho duas perguntas são muito
recorrentes é um acidente porque que eu
preciso aprender isso
isso é fácil de explicar porque a gente
precisa aprender sobre muitas coisas
porque a gente ia se alguém pedir no
mundo todo a gente precisa é aprender
sobre nosso corpo como é que ele
funciona ea gente precisa aprender sobre
o meio ambiente a gente precisa aprender
sobre por que a gente vive essa situação
essa situação atual econômica e social
que a gente precisa saber um pouco de
história a gente tem que se localizar a
gente vai aprender gostoso aprender
agora quando eles me perguntam por que
eu tenho que decorar
nem sei lá um indicativo do sujeito à
ação coordenada assim desde que assim
dedica jogar o temática nematelmintos
ele platelmintos é briófitas de
pteridófitas nessa hora eu falo pros
fico é mesmo que tem de devolver a prova
assim nesse momento eu confesso para
vocês que eu fico chateada ao mesmo
tempo não posso deixar que fossem
resposta então a primeira resposta que
eu dou é assim ó faz o seguinte tem
coisas que a gente fica um pouco sem
sentido mas não tem problema porque a
gente pode combinar vamos atravessar
isso portal que é chato pra poder
encontrar um sentido mais verdadeiro ali
na frente embora eu acho que isso por si
só é um sentido mas ainda não é o
sentido todo porque o sentido todo ele
vem quando esse sujeito descobre que ele
está fazendo a tarefa não é pra entregar
professor que eles são muito a senhora
que saco
hoje eu vou pra casa fazer um trabalho
de responder um questionário de 45
perguntas professora de história aí
porque eu te esqueci o nosso caderno que
as opõe que celular um caderno de você
coloca as suas dúvidas
saiu do meu cabelo é o seu caderno
então quando essas partes começam a
conversar a gente começa a caminhar para
um outro lugar
entendendo a necessidade de cada
segmento desse sociedade escola família
professor aluno e porque na verdade é e
eu muitas vezes eu sou aquela pessoa que
vou dar a notícia assim ó vamos lembrar
que a gente está no mesmo barco senão a
gente começa a remar pra com direções
diferentes na verdade é porque é pra
ajudar aquela pessoinha aquele estudante
pequenininho que vai virar um
adolescente que vai virar um estudante
universitário
a seguir a seguir o seu caminho na vida
então a gente está junto é pra isso e aí
a coisa muda de lugar porque quando esse
estudante que achava que estava fazendo
tudo para a escola ou para o professor
ele entende que quando ele vem com uma
prova diz kaká marcílio era só eu já vi
que o rei três questões por atenção duas
eu não vi o anunciado até o final 13
porque realmente eu não prestei atenção
não tava na hora que eu não me lembro
desse conteúdo essa pessoa está pronta
para deixar o consultório
tá tomando de posse do seu próprio
caminho
e aí o meu trabalho já tá chegando no
final com ela que essa é a ideia de que
esse trabalho não seja um trabalho pra
sempre que seja um trabalho de eu te
empresto a minha vontade eu te apresento
alguns recursos você escolhe quais são
os melhores recursos pra você e vai
muitas vezes está na hora de ir e os
pássaros de chamar um cadinho porque
eles estão com medo que isso se perca
então a gente precisa também é cultivar
um olhar de confiança de uma vez
apropriada a pessoa vai que de vez em
quando a gente pode lembrar pode ajudar
pode chegar mas o caminho é naquele ser
então quando isso acontece é a sensação
que vai dando é de missão cumprida
e aí estava pensando no tema porque meu
tempo era cultivando os nossos frutos e
depois eu fiquei pensando que talvez o
tema pudesse ser como tivemos a nossa
humanidade porque na verdade eu penso
que a matriz né
a árvore ou celular os galhos né
os braços um desses aspectos desses
lugares é o estudante comissão pode ser
profissional é o pai ea mãe é o namorado
então a gente se a gente cultiva a
humanidade cultiva a humanidade para mim
significa uma conversa constante da
mente que pensa realmente que sente a
gente exercitar uma escuta empática a
gente poder olhar o outro esse olhar
primeiro que a gente não oferece nada
pra ninguém que a gente não faça com a
gente mesmo
então não adianta a gente fala nele você
super bacana com o aluno eu vou olhar
pra ele entendeu a necessidade de
licitar um farrapo
se você não tá olhando pra você então é
poder cultivar e se essa escuta esse
olhar simpático para você mesmo em
primeiro lugar para poder oferecer isso
para o outro porque aí deixa de ser
alguma coisa de fora pra dentro
se alguma coisa que é e aí nem o
professor nem escola nem e terapeutas
você engodos aquilo é verdade e quando a
gente está falando alguma coisa que é
verdade não precisa de muitas palavras
os alunos dos estudantes às pessoas elas
entendem então e talvez e cultivando a
humanidade para que ela dê bons frutos
principalmente
os estudantes que a gente está falando
disso aqui mas bom seres humanos bons
profissionais bons pais bons governantes
é por aí
e aí é porque fiquei pensando assim o
que é importante pra gente na vida de
verdade encontrar o nosso lugar no mundo
ea escola é um dos pontos de partida
para isso isso não muda pode ser o
diretor da escola pode ser o coordenador
pode ser o professor pode ser as pessoas
que organizam ted pode ser minha filha
pode ser quem for
todo ser humano deseja encontrar um
lugar de conforto na sua existência ea
escola é esse lugar de quem eu sou o que
eu vim fazer aqui que eu tenho aqui de
bacana pra oferecer para o mundo que eu
tenho é mais ou menos mas se olhar mais
e tiver vontade e dedicação eu
desenvolvo esse sim é o lugar da escola
então pra e fechando aqui é eu queria
dizer sim a gente tá pensando como vou
fechar essa conversa
e aí pensei em duas coisas né onde e
como foi interessante e me observar esse
processo de pensar na minha fala para
vocês porque eu sou fora da caixinha
só fechei a minha conversa vou contar
pra vocês hoje
e aí eu me sinto como os estudantes que
têm precisam de um tempo maior que tem
que fazer sentido que tem olhar pra cara
das pessoas têm que sentir o campo
energético pra mim isso é importante
para que as coisas aconteçam e ao mesmo
tempo eu fiquei eu tenho tinha um
adolescente que falava sempre assim pra
mim você pode dar a notícia para o mundo
que dentro de mim uma pessoa e aí porque
ele até fazia uma cena assim ó minha mãe
chega em casa isso já tem os três anos
mas eu nunca esqueci ea porta de entrada
da minha sala é assim aqui tem um lavabo
aí a minha mãe fala assim e aí fez a
tarefa
sai o boletim melhorar a nota de
matemática eu queria que ela me dissesse
oi tudo bem
é claro que a mãe não faz isso porque
ela acha que está ferindo o filho por
causa disso ela faz rota completa que
ela tem pouco tempo e ela tem que dar
conta de checar se está tudo bem com
aquele estudantes
então eu vou tomar um pouquinho prestado
essa fala de um adolescente que diz
avisa pro mundo que aqui dentro uma
pessoa
e aí eu fiquei pensando acho que eu
posso eu já conheço
que assim pra mim é assim é acho que
hoje eu posso me reconhecer como um ser
humano que é educadora que é terapeuta
que é um pouco artesã que é um pouco
tradutora porque às vezes eu me vejo
traduzindo as necessidades da escola pra
família da família à escola do professor
para os pais do aluno professor do
professor o aluno então tipo talvez a
abertura simultânea mesmo consultório e
aí só isso tudo mas dentro de mim
mora uma professora eu saí da escola mas
a escola não serginho então isso é uma
coisa que faz o diferencial mega gigante
então e até meu trabalho como terapeuta
porque eu acho que eu não conseguiria
ter o olhar que eu tenho
se eu não tivesse lá no começo me
tornado uma educadora uma professora
então como um todo orgulho sou um ser
humano e que dentro mora uma professora
obrigada
[Música]